which famous Kris is your soulmate no
matter what you win oh that's a nice
thing hi I'm Chris Pratt and I'm taking
a quiz right now to determine which
famous Chris is my soulmate
choose a must have quality that you most
want in a Chris rock-hard ABS a sense of
humor
gorgeous facial hair thick thighs arms
and butt woken this a suave sense of
style I think you have to have a sense
of humor choose a bad pick-up line that
would actually work on you we're your
parents Bevers cuz damn that would work
okay I'm here what do you want for your
next wish if you were a booger I'd pick
you on a scale of 1 to America how free
are you tonight are you trash because
I'd like to take you out I'd settle for
you ooh not that one I would say on a
scale of 1 to America how free are you
tonight choose an ideal first date with
your Chris dinner in a movie weekend
brunch comedy show picnic at the beach
or trivia night at a local bar no no no
no I'm gonna go with first date comedies
no picnic at the beach ooh I hope I get
Emsworth choose a famous power couple to
go on a double date with you and your
Chris oh snap I got either Ryan Reynolds
and Blake Lively that would be a good
one jay-z and Beyonce
Neil Patrick Harris and David Burtka oh
man this is gonna be so hard to pick
David and Victoria Beckham Kim
Kardashian and Kanye West yes Ellen
DeGeneres and Portia
Oh first of all if I go if I take my
Chris on a date with either any of these
Power couples I'm getting late okay cuz
that is impressive
I'm gonna go Ellen Ellen and Portia and
it's a tough one cuz I also love them
all I'm going Ellen Ellen and Portia
double date what's up girls finally
choose a cinematic situation to rescue
your Chris from he's surrounded by a
group of angry raptors he's in jail cell
guarded by superhumans he's on an
operation table in an et spaceship
it's romantic he's stuck in the attic of
a haunted house
he's on a sinking ship surrounded by
sharks he's tied up in the basement of a
serial killer sinking ship huh my
soulmate is this succulent Chris Pine oh
man so Chris Pine is my soul mate yeah
lucky me because this Chris is refined a
F Chris Pine is the most polished of the
Chris's he's a man of elegance and taste
oh god he's not gonna like me with Chris
Pine as a soul mate you can expect
weekend trips to the museum a bottle of
red wine with every dinner trips to the
most romantic getaways you can imagine
okay
cheers to that well I'll take everything
but the museum I'll get him off museums
we'll just go once or twice and I'll
just embarrass him
well hey Chris if you're watching I I
just I don't know I got butterflies in
my stomach but there could we make this
happen I don't know but you know is
there a possibility guy like you guy
like me he could just be happy together
find some some semblance of happiness
just a partnership so I have friendship
friendship with benefits and you know
[ __ ] museums okay that's all I ask
Chris Pine
that was fun what do you think I'm gonna
get I'm gonna give up OMG
[Music]